into my life came Chuck Jones again he
had seen the Light Brigade and he'd
shown that this is the ABC people
showing it to them and he said I want
you to animate Dickens Christmas Carol
and I for a half an hour or television
he said we can get you the top money so
you'd be able to do it and I said but we
can't can I do it can I design it myself
and he said no no I want 1850s
illustrations like the Light Brigade I
said God will never do it I mean we got
nine months to do it and he look can we
do it in pencil
you know just pencil drawings he said of
course as long as it's in this style
that's what they want
that is what they won and he left me
alone again marvelous
Thank You Chuck he turned and he said I
want two things I want to I want some
[ __ ] Bells jingling at the front and I
wanted a pan over the London rooftops
and we didn't major you know anyway and
Ken Harris nobody we thought dick nobody
can animate this stuff and maybe you can
but the rest of us can and Ken the it
was there and I I gave him I did a few
main drawings of Scrooge widows
waking up in the morning and and next
morning and Kenda left it with Ken in
the morning in Cayman Russia is perfect
and we knew oh we can do this thing so
everybody learned from Ken again and he
did a lot of the stuff I caricatured his
character him kind of a Scrooge and his
hands all the way through them so this
was we slept under our desks and
everything for this thing we ended up it
was a tremendous race against time so I
remember I was doing nine backgrounds a
day as well as animating as well as
cleaning up as well as directing it and
it was just a rush and when I finished
it it it well to my support
it was a big hit for a while and
technically we were able to get in for
the Oscars chuk chuk put it in and we
won the Oscar and even better than that
I got a letter from milk call saying how
impressed he was with it and he said I
don't know how you did it when you just
had all those other lazy bastards